let's dive into head first the Friday
Feed Bag AKA Friday feedback also known
as really ignorant people write to me
and I struggle to explain the things
that they say we're going to start today
with someone named Zoya zorai zoyara
zavova
who says you mud be do lonely in your
dungeon I know it's your job to talk bad
about Trump Republican conservatives
that's how you make views but does it
truly bring you happiness when was the
last time you felt free peaceful and
joyful go to church this Sunday seek and
you will find the capital T truth oh boy
it's hard to take this seriously
and engage with it in anything
approximating a serious manner
but
um it actually does bring me happiness
to be able to and this is no disrespect
to anyone who likes it but to be able to
not have some boss waiting for me who
says sir we start at 905 and you didn't
get here until 908 this morning and to
be able to talk about or focus on
whatever I want any day if I want to
take time off I take time off like that
it really brings me happiness to not
only have that work schedule and
situation but also to be able to have
such a great Community present company
of course accept it as far as this
message is concerned uh of people who I
engage with and it really does bring me
happiness so I know that that's of
course the number one concert concern of
zoyara zavova but uh no need to worry
about me thank you very much DW says
Pac-Man can you please explain explain
why you never talk about bidens and
Clinton's unclassified documents because
they're not classified I'm guessing
that's an error only a president can
declassify documents not a vice
president or a secretary of state I
wonder why most commenters on this
channel are only concerned about Trump's
actions could it be because they will
let it slide if they agree with the
person's politics no no no
how many times have I talked about
Biden's documents and Hillary Clinton's
documents at this point dozens and
dozens the reality is the facts are
different the way our correspondent Luke
Beasley explained to some of those
magadonians magapotamians earlier this
week in Pickens South Carolina the facts
are different Joe Biden had a small
number of documents they were
immediately returned when found there
was no alleged obstruction there was no
alleged witness tampering there was no
showing the documents to random people
on the Portico of Mar-A-Lago or whatever
okay there was none of that Hillary
Clinton yes she was careless that was
the determination but an investigation
determined no crimes were committed is I
talk about it it's just that it's a
different set of facts what this person
really should be saying is I don't care
that it's a different set of facts I
want Biden and Hillary to be indicted to
just because of their partisan uh uh uh
affiliation I don't want it to just be
Trump well maybe Trump's the only one
who committed crimes have to consider
that have to consider that uh next
person who goes by the username life is
a gift cherish every moment all right
says I was born in the United States of
America in 1950 for most of my life I
thought of myself as a patriot and I
admired and respected others who
referred to themselves as Patriots that
all changed on January 6 2021 now I am
very cautious around anyone who calls
themselves a patriot if this is
patriotism I am very concerned for the
future of the United States of America
well of course they're correct and I've
spoken about this before the right has
obtained a monopoly on patriotism not on
patriotism the thing on patriotism the
word and we've spoken before about the
difference between patriotism and
Nationals and we've done that we've gone
down this rabbit hole before
it is not
a uniquely right-wing thing and I would
argue there is nothing patriotic about
the modern Maga movement it is patriotic
to say hey you know what we're Americans
we're not going to let anyone standard
of living fall below a certain level
it's patriotic to say we'll make sure
everybody has housing
and Food and Health Care wow that's
patriotism okay that is just as valid as
whatever cockamamie version of
patriotism these people on the right
ascribe to that word
uh Stephen Rhoden noticing what's been
happening on our tick tocks and says 500
000 on Tick Tock but how many on truth
truth essential yeah uh listen we're not
we're not on Truth Central or truth
social but I have to tell you what is
happening on Tick Tock is unbelievable
now I know Tick Tock may be banned and
all these different things listen I get
it okay I have no control over that to
the extent that it's a platform on on
which we can get our message out
I think we're up to 530 000 followers on
Tick Tock much of it because of the
great work of my colleague John in
helping us build that platform much of
it because of the shift to short form
content
I I know that this is really difficult
to believe
we now are seeing as many monthly views
on Tick Tock as we get on our YouTube
channel and we've been on Tick Tock like
a year and a half and we've been on
YouTube more than a decade and the
YouTube channel is Big okay it is
stunning the growth that we're having
there and the important thing is we are
getting the message out at this point I
think I get recognized on the street
as much for hey you're the tick tock guy
uh as as I do for YouTube it's an
incredible thing Colin Peter Kowski
says without Christianity you have chaos
are you blind you know whenever I see
comments like these the same thought
always occurs to me
which is are you telling me that the
only thing keeping you
from acting in a disgusting or criminal
way or immoral way
is your belief that Jewish Carpenter
Jesus died and was resurrected and was
born to a virgin and there was this Ark
and eating shrimp is bad and like you're
saying if you didn't have that you'd be
out murdering people for people to say
we would have no moral compass if we
didn't have God telling us what to do
you're saying the only thing keeping you
from murdering people
is that God says it's not a good thing
to do that's scary that's really really
scary and so I struggle with this type
of statement listen if the community and
the idea of something bigger than
yourself from religion is a positive
thing for you and it helps you to
connect with those around you and have a
optimistic outlook on life oh absolutely
there is no denying the importance of
religion
separating of course from specific
religious beliefs there's no way that we
can minimize some of the positive things
about religious community in history and
negative things as well we can talk
about but without Christianity you have
chaos
very very tough very very tough and by
the way
countries with very little Christianity
often have very little crime which would
be another way to say they're not
particularly chaotic Libby Shipman
commented on Facebook and says the thing
about Chris Christie is that no matter
how good he campaigns it's obvious that
he cannot control his eating so how can
he be trusted to control anything else
and Linda Anderson says that is a
ridiculous comment yeah I mean listen
it's a pretty stupid thing to say
he can't control his eating so what he
he has a worse you'd ra you'd sooner
give Trump the nuclear codes because
Chris Christie eats a lot I mean it just
it's it's it's quite a strange
non-sequitur it really is
um
you know it's less about refuting the
specifics of this but more about
you're allowed to decide who to vote for
using absolutely any rubric or standard
and many of these people do they're the
message we should get is that there are
people like Libby
who would say I guess I'd rather Trump
because Chris Christie is eats a lot by
the way Trump's also obese which is a
whole other story but maybe maybe Libby
prefers
I don't know who's thin Vivek ramaswamy
because Vivek can control the amount he
eats and Chris Christie can't it the
this is what we're up against and we are
much better off just finding people and
getting them to vote rather than
convincing people like Libby to change
their minds because they're probably not
going to a Reddit user knower of stuff
remember the David Pacman show subreddit
is at uh davidpackman.com Reddit knower
of stuff says are we at a point where
conservatives are simultaneously buying
and trying to ban electric vehicles to
own the libs like wouldn't it be
surprising if you had conservative Elon
Musk Fanatics who bought Teslas
partially because they think it will
trigger liberals by supporting a must
company but on the other hand you still
have most conservatives who are
anti-environmentalist and hate electric
vehicles like Marjorie Taylor green who
call him calls them a threat to the
country lawmaker in Wyoming who pretty
much tried to ban them basically to own
the lips yeah it's it's it reminds me of
the vaccine
Donald Trump deserves all of the credit
for developing these vaccines which
don't work are killing people and I
absolutely will not take Trump deserves
credit for that he's way better than Joe
Biden what wait so is the vaccine good
or bad doesn't matter it is a very
similar thing with Twitter it's easier
because it's like okay Twitter is less
about lifestyle it's less about broader
political beliefs it's like you're on
Twitter or you're not you like Elon
musk's handling of it or you don't the
electric vehicle one is interesting
because a lot of these right-wingers
hate electric vehicles
but at the same time they do think that
it is an easy way now to trigger the
left by supporting Elon Musk so maybe
what they'll do is they'll go and buy a
Tesla to support musk but then they'll
burn it I don't know or something like
that like the people who are shooting
Bud Lights with with shotguns it's all
very very weird all right lastly Big D
says to me on Instagram
this guy is on the payroll of the left
don't believe him he has not talked a
word about the hunter Biden indictment
thus guy is sketchy sketchy is
misspelled well Big D couple different
things I've been talking about Hunter
Biden for years I was away at a wedding
the week that Hunter struck a plea deal
and I have spoken about it since
multiple times so every single one of
these claims is false by the way I'm on
the payroll of the left if by the
payroll of the left you mean that there
are people on the left who get
memberships on my website and support my
work guilty is charged if you mean
payroll of the left as in the Democratic
establishment the DNC George Soros or
whoever are funding this program the
answer is they are not and I challenge
you to present a shred of evidence a
shred of evidence for a decade these
folks have been saying that you must be
on the payroll of the DNC not even a
Democrat
why would they pay me doesn't make a lot
of sense
snbc must be paying you why would MSNBC
pay people who aren't even on their
Network very strange not much of an
understanding of how
anything Works quite frankly uh find
some kind of proof that any of these
organizations are paying me
and I will say you got me you got me I
did everything right and they indicted
me okay I will say it here uh all right
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
sign up at joinpakman.com folks in all
seriousness the children's critical
thinking book is available
for pre-order on Kindle and in paperback
right now I hold in front of me proof
number one print this is the first proof
okay this is an historic item uh go to
davidpackman.com book donate them to
your kids class bring them around to
school libraries
uh give them as gifts this is really
something special that we're doing
davidpackman.com book we'll see you on
the bonus show if you're not on the
bonus show then I'll see you back here
Monday